[Music]
[Applause]
I'm joined at the ftth conference in
Amsterdam by Thomas Renault of Iliad one
of the most innovative providers in
France so much it's really nice to talk
to you you I think were the first people
to bring fiber into the French market
and you're a real you're really really
innovator aren't you yeah we started our
fiber project back in 2006 so it is been
a long journey between pushing the right
regulation putting in place to the
processes but today we are the number
one alternative operator in terms of
fiber in France we have 10 million
connectable circuits we have a 3,000
employees dedicated to the rollout of
fiber in France and on top of that we
are the number one alternative operator
in terms of subscriber it took us 12
years to get the first million of
subscribers and 2018 is really a year of
transition a year of an acceleration
because we increase that one number of
subscribers by 50% and if it took us 12
years to get the first million of
subscribers it will take us only 18
months to get the second million so we
are in that unique moment in time in the
history of a French fiber I think you
were saying the opening of the French
market has helped give us an update on
the French to the regulatory position
yes so it's a very interesting mechanism
we have basically a three different
footprints the dance zone we all invest
on our own and in the medium and low
density zone there is a co-investment
mechanism so clearly so far the opening
of the French telecom market has been a
success
in terms of purchasing power for the
citizens in terms of reducing the
digital divide in terms also of
investment cycle but we should pay
attention on the right implementation of
the of that regulation and as you move
forward what for you are some of the
next challenges fiber is still a big
challenge and we have to pay a lot of
attention regarding the implementation
of that regulation specifically in the
co-investment scheme because in some
cases the co investment is done for
example with the incumbent and then in
combat as strengthen its position thanks
to fiber recently and so we pay a lot of
attention to two topics
there should be no operational
discrimination and the equivalents of
input is very important and two we
consider also that there should be a
Chinese wall between the world cell team
in charge of the co-investment mechanism
and they have a clear view of where we
invest and the retail team of the
incumbent so this is a clear topic for
us clearly for us fiber is the number
one strategic topic we do believe in the
future of fiber but we need to have a
proper regulation and we need also that
strong political will on that topic okay
well thank you very much for joining us
today thank you Brian
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]